la capitale belge c'est un peu la mecque
de la bande dessinée c'est ici que sont
éteintes un gaston lagaffe ou encore
lucky luke
pat mobile y est né au congo il est
arrivé à bruxelles en 2003 c'est dans
une librairie de la capitale qu'il
évoque le personnage emblématique de son
enfance passée à kinshasa même temps
c'est la référence par excellence de
ces thèmes et transporté mois betty
kinois en
mairie
à kinshasa on trouve plus de bédéistes
dans tout le reste de l'afrique
l'explication est simple les belges ont
quitté leur colonie congolaise en 1960
mais leurs bandes dessinées sont restés
au pays
j'ai pratiquement lui tous les tintin on
et possédant qu'un seul album par
exemple parce qu'on sait changer on
s'échangeait des albums on pouvait faire
des kilomètres pour en trouver un une
passion qui aujourd'hui l'a conduit à
devenir dessinateur et c'est dans son
appartement qu'il nous fait découvrir
son travail alors et si c'est bon
l'endroit où je passe le plus clair de
mon temps
pat était déjà dessinateur au congo s'il
a quitté le pays à l'époque ce n'était
pas son choix aujourd'hui réfugié
politique il ne souhaite pas vraiment
aborder le sujet j'ai des circonstances
malheureuses en 2003 qui m'ont poussé à
quitter le pays donc je travaille en
tant que dessinateur de presse et on y
voit donc depuis depuis je suis parti et
depuis 2003 je suis en belgique j'essaie
de trouver mon voir loin de chez lui pas
de carte toujours ses origines sous les
traits de son crayon et quand il crée un
super héros le personnage ne manque pas
de références il a une soeur du costume
comme ça qui rappelle
le costume de danseurs de
des danseurs traditionnels africains
et là j'ai essayé de rendre aussi
hommage aux masques africains aux
statuts et à l'afrique
avec ses dessins pâte et c'est aussi à
sa manière de changer le regard des
occidentaux sur les africains c'est très
important pour donner l'image de
l'afrique que moi j'ai connaît
une image qui est différent des l'image
que moi je vois à travers les médias
occidentaux du moins aujourd'hui patrie
de sa passion il travaille actuellement
sur son premier album qui sera édité en
belgique et regorge de projets pour le
public congolais
[Musique]
direction le centre-ville pâte a rendez
vous avec son ami alain pas loukou l'une
des figures de la bd congolaise installé
en belgique depuis huit ans alain est
déjà l'auteur de quatre albums un début
prometteur qui n'a pu accomplir cas des
milliers de kilomètres de kinshasa là
bas les structures manquent pour vivre
grâce au neuvième art
mais en belgique la concurrence est rude
pas de trace de leurs oeuvres dans cette
vitrine
honda bande dessinée eux
encore belge c'est un peu comme au lit
ou quoi
et à hollywood tu as fait une figuration
dans un film hollywoodien c'est déjà
quelque chose que tu vois
si bruxelles et le hollywood de la bd le
spielberg local s'appelle rg l'auteur
des aventures de tintin 24 albums vendus
à plusieurs centaines de millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde entier en
1930 r j'ai écrit tintin au congo le
pays est alors la grande colonie belge à
l'époque les dessins sont à l'image des
stéréotypes de l'afrique vue par les
européens des caricatures que nos deux
bédéistes congolais prennent plutôt avec
philosophie
en fait quand on crée gable et déjà la
morphologie des gens dessinée dans
tintin au congo c'est pas de cette
jument comment voulez vous construire
[Rires]
[Musique]
non c'est pas
comment veux tu que je je je je
m'identifie à des personnages comme ça
c'est des fins
jamais représenté comme ça 80 ans après
en 2010 cette bande dessinée est
toujours controversé
l'album a fait l'objet de condamnations
pour contenus racistes et en 2007 il est
supprimé des rayons pour enfants en
angleterre qu'on enlève sa des commerces
mois voilà franchement je m'en balance
complètement quoi je m'en balance
complètement c'est un truc que
j'achèterai pour lire une histoire voir
un peu comment les gens pensaient
à l'époque et nos âmes et notre premier
rallye c'était un temps où il n'y a rien
à dire de faut bien faire la part des
choses quoi le belem il a été conçu
on enfin notre proche à quelqu'un qu'on
aime bien sans rancune pour pathé alain
rg reste toujours la référence
direction m'a tomber le quartier
congolais de bruxelles
c'est ici que se sont regroupés les
premiers immigrants congolais en fait
c'est le rendez-vous incontournable dé
comme valet à bora bora pour sortir
avant le week-end
ce soir c'est samedi
pat on profite pour rafraîchir sa coupe
donc ces sites qui réprouvent l'ambiance
à les sons
les odeurs
en belgique environ 80000 personnes sont
d'origine congolaise c'est la diaspora
la plus importante dans l'eau et dans ce
quartier c'est toute la culture du pays
qui est à portée de main parfois on se
perd un peu quoi parce qu'on devient
finalement des métis culturelles et en
venant ici on se replonge dans la
culture chinoise et on s'en inspire pour
pourtant crié des choses qui rassemble
congolais quoi parce que ça c'est quand
même important
un métissage culturel indispensable à
nos deux artistes et qui ici à bruxelles
trouve tout son sens
[Musique]
m
non
j'ai créé la cour des formes
[Musique]
on est vraiment les toits
même